Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I apologize for the delays during last week,
I always put out notifications about such
events on Twitter and Facebook, make sure
to follow us there so you Fellow Scholars
know about these well in advance.
And I have to say, during this time, I really
missed you and making videos so much!
This video is a quick update on what has happened
since, and I'd also like to assure you that
the next Two Minute Papers episode is already
in the works and is going to arrive soon.
Very soon.
Patreon is a platform where you can support
your favorite creators with monthly recurring
tips and get cool perks in return.
We have quite a few supporters who are really
passionate about the show, and during the
making of the last few episodes, we have encountered
severe hardware issues.
There were freezes, random restarts, blue
screens of death constantly, and the computer
was just too unstable to record and edit Two
Minute Papers.
The technicians checked it out and found that
quite a few parts would have to be replaced,
and I figured that this would be a great time
to replace this old configuration.
So, we have ordered the new Two Minute Papers
rig, and the entire purchase happened with
the help of you, our Patreon supporters!
We were able to replace it effortlessly, which
is just amazing.
Words fail me to describe how grateful I am
for your generous support, and I am still
stunned by this.
It is just unfathomable to me that I am just
sitting here in a room with a microphone,
having way too much fun with research papers,
and many of you enjoy this series enough to
support it, and it had come to this.
You Fellow Scholars make Two Minute Papers
happen.
Thanks so much.
I'll try to squeeze in a bit of footage of
the new rig, and transparency above all, will
post the configuration in the video description
box for the more curious minds out there.
What I can say at this point, is that this
new rig renders videos three times as quickly
as the previous one.
And even though these are just short videos,
the rendering times for something in full
HD and 60 fps are surprisingly long even when
run on the graphical card.
Well, not anymore.
So, one more time, thank you so much for supporting
the series.
This is absolutely amazing, it really is.
This was a quick update video, the next episode
is coming soon, and I'll try my very best
so we can be back at our regular schedule
of two videos per week.
Lots of spectacular works are on our list,
stay tuned!
Oh, and by the way, we have Fellow Scholars
watching from all around the world.
And in the meantime, some of them have started
translating our episodes to German, Portuguese,
Spanish and Italian.
For some reason, I cannot see the names of
the kind people who took their time to contribute,
so I'd like to kindly thank you for your work,
it makes Two Minute Papers accessible to even
more people, which is amazing.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!